a very short time from now in a theater
not too far away star wars the rise of
Skywalker's hitting the big screen to
close out the sequel trilogy and a
Skywalker saga as a whole here's
everything you need to know before you
go to a galaxy far far away
[Music]
not only is this the finale of the nine
part story excluding spin-offs and
animated features but this may be the
last time we'll be seeing the original
trilogy characters and hearing the
original score from John Williams I mean
can you imagine a star wars without
[Music]
so where does the rise of Skywalker fit
in the series episode 9 we'll finish out
the Skywalker saga concluding the
long-running storyline that began with a
new hope back in 1977 and has continued
through the original trilogy the
prequels and recently the force awakens
and the last Jedi as for the plot we've
only heard that it takes place a year
after the events of the last Jedi and
then it's an adventure rey finn poe and
the rest of the group experiences
together and what's happened in the
skywalker saga so far well if I gave you
all the details we'd be creating another
Star Wars Episode essentially so let's
sum them up a bit
the prequels the rise of Skywalker is
the ninth episode of the Skywalker saga
and the third chapter of the third
trilogy the plot of the series starts
with the events of the prequel trilogy
when Anakin Skywalker was discovered as
a child and then trained to become the
chosen one of the Jedi an order of
galactic peace makers who wield the
powers of the force for good
but Anakin became distracted by love and
then was corrupted by the influence of
the evil Senator Palpatine remember this
name leading to his descent to the
darkside the original trilogy in episode
is 4 through 6 which take place nearly
two decades later Palpatine has become
emperor of the galaxy and Anakin has
transformed into his masked enforcer the
Sith Lord known as Darth Vader this
group of movies follows his secret
children Luke Skywalker and Princess
Leia as they're joined by smuggler Han
Solo his copilot Chewbacca and droid
c-3po and r2d2 to lead a rebellion
against the Empire and it's attempts to
oppress the galaxy with moon-sized super
weapons called Death Star's now on to
the current and final trilogy starting
with the force awakens while the Rebel
Alliance defeated the Empire at the end
of the original trilogy decades later
the galaxy is divided once again in the
force awakens new heroes rey poe dameron
droid bb-8 and former stormtrooper finn
join Han Leia and the resistance against
new enemies the first order leather moon
sized super weapon
killer bass Han and Leia's own son kylo
Ren is the villainous enforcer and at
the end of the movie killed his father
the last Jedi in the eighth episode of
the Skywalker saga Rey found the now
reclusive Luke Skywalker in hopes of
bringing him back to fight the first
order which was on the verge of wiping
out the resistance but he wasn't
interested
Rey and kylo then temporarily joined
forces to kill the evil supreme leader
Snoke but when kylo Ren continued to go
after his mother and the rest of the
resistance Luke confronted his nephew
and ultimately gave his own life to aid
their escape and survival
so who's returning at the end of the
last Jedi most of the main cast were
still with us that means we'll be seeing
the main characters rape OH
finn and newly in charge villain kylo
ren also back are Lapita and the young
go as Maz Kanata domhnall gleeson as
general Hux kelly marie tran as rose
taiko jonas Otomo as Chewbacca Anthony
Daniels as c-3po and Billie lourd as
lieutenant conics what about Luke and
Leia Luke Skywalker died in the last
Jedi but actor Mark Hamill has been
revealed as a returning cast member for
the rise of Skywalker so Luke will
appear in some form presumably as a
force ghost
sadly actress Carrie Fisher passed away
after filming the last Jedi but did you
know thanks to some previously unused
footage she'll appear in the film
director JJ Abrams says of the decision
we desperately loved Carrie Fisher
finding a truly satisfying conclusion to
the Skywalker saga without her eluded us
we were never going to recast or use a
CG character with the support and
blessing from her daughter Billie lourd
we have found a way to honor Carey's
legacy and role as Leia and episode 9 is
anyone else coming back from the
original trilogy yes and one of them has
been long overdue to return fans have
been wondering if Lando Calrissian would
ever show up in the current Star Wars
trilogy the popular scoundrel from the
original trilogy was a big part of the
Empire
Strikes Back and Return of the Jedi and
his absence from the force awakens and
the last Jedi left us all curious what
became of the traitor turned hero of the
rebellion fleet meanwhile we just met
his younger self as portrayed by Donald
Glover in solo a Star Wars story did you
know Billy Dee Williams hasn't been on
screen as Lando since 1983 but he voiced
the role in animated series and video
games as revealed by the initial teaser
for the new movie there'll be one more
major character from not just the
original trilogy but also the prequel
trilogy making his return after a long
absence Emperor Palpatine aka Darth
Sidious actor Ian McDiarmid who's been
portraying the villain since Return of
the Jedi will reprise his role once
again for the rise of Skywalker how did
he survive his apparent death and Return
of the Jedi
we shall see are there any newcomers for
the rise of Skywalker Keri Russell is
one of the more notable additions to the
cast is she a good guy or a bad guy
her character called Zuri bliss is a
human criminal of some kind who has a
connection to Poe Dameron and it's said
to be an action heavy role she considers
herself neutral without allegiances to
either the resistance or the first order
but given her past with one of the
former's heroes we can probably expect
her to help and their cause against kylo
Ren and the dark side while remaining a
scoundrel by Nature she will be joined
by fellow newcomers Naomi a key as a
tribal warrior and resistance Ally Jana
Richard II Grant who plays a
high-ranking first-order general and
dominic monaghan
a longtime admitted Star Wars fan who
plays a resistance trooper we will also
be introduced to a new little droid
called do sure to be another fan
favorite so now you know and now you can
go see the rise of Skywalker in theaters
December 20th
[Music]
[Applause]
you